okay hypothetically speaking there's uh
somebody who wants to
shoot music videos yeah
kind of follow your path
they got five grand in the bank
what camera what lens
what are they getting
to get the most bang for their buck to
try to you know maybe they're in
missoula montana and they want to start
shooting music videos yeah for their
homie what are they what are they
getting give me the breakdown of like
the gear that you could get for about
five grand honestly if you're trying to
get in music videos i always tell people
like you got to believe in the artist
you got me like you got to listen to the
music and like i think equipment is
definitely you know helpful and i would
definitely rock with that ronin and that
sony a7s and you know just put pop a
memory memory card in there and just
have fun any sort of lens the rokinon
you know lens set you know okay yeah low
light you can shoot at night time you
could shoot a day um really really clean
glass but um and you probably get that
all under like probably four grand but i
always say like it doesn't matter who
you shoot videos for if like the song is
not good if the artist doesn't have that
confidence that he's gonna be the
biggest artist
and i saw that a lot in myself so then i
started trying to find artists with that
same energy you got me so when i saw
russ i was like yo i was listening to
music and he's he's talking that [ __ ] if
you listen you got me sure and even back
in the day like i was like 2014 2015 he
was you know going he was rapping about
like how he's gonna be the biggest one
day and like that's the type of
confidence you want in artists and
that's that's kind of what i bet on you
got me and i was like and same thing
with jake miller like you know he had a
really beautiful family and they were
also working he had a manager that
managed jason darillo and he had a good
team set up and i'm like oh this guy's
gonna win yeah i mean it's not just like
the music it's also like the structure
and you know their surroundings and they
had that so
so
you said the sony a7s yeah the sony a7s
the ronin um the rokinon lens set and
you know um get some nd filters you know
and some circular polarizers you know if
you're shooting outside and um honestly
a lot of youtube tutorials because
that's how i learned you know would you
say final cut or premiere um i'm gonna
go premiere but i started off final cut
um nowadays final cut has its perks so
it's premiere so it's just about you
know yeah i know people some people use
both and then there are people who are
just so married to like one or the other
like i i know final cut guys
like him and with the man bun over there
just won't let go final cut
well you know it's honestly really just
depends on who you are and what you're
trying to do but i also like i think
there's a there's a there's a big thing
and also like what i started learning
because i didn't learn this early is um
you know a story you know what are you
trying to say what's the theme you know
what's the universal theme that
everyone's going to connect to you get i
mean like when we shoot russ is exposed
and we basically pull up a bunch of
archival concert footage we shot that
video lily in two minutes it was snowing
in spokane washington and i literally
said yo stand right there we're gonna
shoot one performance i took that
performance i mixed it up archival
archival footage of the tour and then i
just basically put up text you get me um
same thing with what they want you know
it was a 40 minute video shot that's
crazy you know i just went there and i
was like damn and we're the first video
coloring on that [ __ ] was so fire yeah
and i learned it through a youtube
tutorial you got me and um i was there
on youtube like looking at how to do
infrared and then going back to da vinci
um that's the coloring program and then
i was like boom and i was just doing
that back and forth and that video was
funny because
uh we were shooting this video and he
was dressing all white he had a glass of
wine and we're like yo this is kind of
whack and we're like shooting this for
30 minutes and we're like this ain't it
so as we're driving back um through a
botanical garden in atlanta um i see
this shed and i'm like yo let's stop
there and i remember i think um i think
travis scott and um ti had a video
called upper echelon that was shot in
like a cabin and i was like maybe i
could do something here and then i
walked to the cab and i was like yeah i
could shoot this how about this russ
let's do like a few takes and let's see
what we get and we did that um he was
performing he was having fun and then i
took it home and then i'm like damn this
video kind of sucks and then i was like
how can i make it different and then in
the editing process that's when i made
the leaves infrared and then next you
know that's kind of like what set this
video off yeah no for sure the coloring
was crazy i feel like was that like uh
that was
that was before that record was
technically that was before he had his
his deal right yeah we shot um the first
video we ever shot was losing control
then it was what they want then it was
do it myself then i was pulled the
trigger and i showed the first three
videos for free and then the fourth
video was um
pull the trigger which russ was you know
at that point had enough money to you
know pay me like seven thousand dollars
for the video [ __ ] yeah that's great
yeah